it's up guys welcome to Oslo comics your
one-stop shop for everything comic book
entertainment I am your host Walter
Bernays yank and we got a big panel
today guys this is a good one we're
talking about our favorite comic book
writers and our favorite comic book
artists before we get to the intro so
these guys want to always remind you to
like the Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome comic show new videos
every Thursday so go ahead and like that
page ok intros we'll start with my left
far left it's Heather Roose what's going
on Heather just really excited to share
some my favorite authors and artists
with you guys yeah cool Porter Brian
Porter sup what's going on man doing
yeah I'm doing good you're doing good
I'm good you sure yeah okay and Ayanna
wait how's it going you excited to talk
about your favorite writer and artist oh
yeah all right cool and our special
guest today mr. Trevor Muller what's up
man not much man thanks so much for
having me on the show really appreciate
it yeah okay well we're gonna get right
into this folks favorite writer we're
gonna go with first let's start with
Trevor favorite writer what's up man new
to the show and also opening a song as
somebody who most of the people from
channel Austin probably don't know that
outside of nostalgia critic stuff I also
write comic books so I'm gonna hopefully
bring a unique perspective to the to the
idea here but so I ended up picking a
writer that I really kind of look up to
and appreciate and have had the
opportunity to work with in a business
capacity before who is Mark Waid and so
mark is the kind of writer who has you
know a reverence for a lot of the
characters that he works on an
understanding of who these characters
are you know has the versatility to work
with a multitude of different artists
which complex story telling is all about
right the writer and the artist working
in conjunction to kind of give this
visual narrative so it makes a lot of
sense so mark is just just this
fantastic guy and you know one of the
nicest people that you'll meet in comics
one of the things to that that I really
didn't really didn't get about Mark
until I ended up reading the new Archie
run which have you guys had a chance to
read that at all yes
so Archie right there's a character
that's existed longer than I have and I
think it's safe to say that I'm the
oldest person sitting at this table and
not a character that gets a lot of press
not a character that has a lot of
interest I feel from from younger
readers and I picked up this new Archie
book with with him and Fiona staples
kind of on the art duties loved her
working on saga right and it's a
complete redesign of the characters and
it's essentially like an episode of
something on the CW but in comic book
form and it's fascinating and from the
word go like it's Archie narrating to
you like Zack Morris from Saved by the
Bell and just sitting there just like
time out let me tell you what's going on
here right and it's the classic Betty
Veronica like fight over Archie but the
twist is is that he's already been in a
relationship with one of them and it
failed because of something called the
lipstick incident right and from the
word go you're just intrigued and hooked
into this world that he starts to craft
in this modern telling of of Riverdale
so absolutely fantastic Kingdom Come
obviously you know a very famous book
from DC Comics I'm sure you guys have
all read this very very different
narrative though right and the diversity
and narrative and voice that Mark Waid
can kind of put out there through
through the different artists that he
works down at the different characters
that he's working on and this was an
opportunity to kind of reimagine a lot
of these characters as older characters
within the universe so absolutely loved
what he did with with this world in this
universe Alex Ross obviously gorgeous
painted artwork on here a lot of
religious overtones that he's kind of
thrown in there because it really kind
of is about the end of innocence and the
end of of mankind as we know it and
again these are just three examples that
I kind of brought from from my
collection because the stipulation that
Walter sent through in the email was
something you have an example of and
right most of my comics are still back
in Michigan but Superman birth right
right is kind of the final example that
I brought on here and people may or may
not know that Man of Steel borrowed very
heavily from a lot of the source
material that was in Superman birth
right which was not unlike archie mark
being asked by DC Comics to kind of
reimagine the Superman character for a
modern
generation and he created the line that
it's not an S on my chest right this
from where I'm from this is the symbol
of hope the difference being is that he
actually puts Superman in situations
where he is inspiring hope versus Man of
Steel which is another conversation
entirely so again just a versatility
that you don't see in a lot of writers
that are out there an understanding of
the medium that exists in a diversity of
voice while maintaining a reverence for
the characters to me really kind of
stood out so that's that's why he's my
favorite I love kingdom comes let's go
on favorite writer Heather but my one of
my favorite writers is Brian Kavon so I
just really like some of the creativity
that he has I think he's a very engaging
storyteller I think he writes really
relatable characters who I hadn't
generally drawn into I like that he adds
a sense of humor every now and then so
even though it could be a serious topic
like pride of Baghdad there is the
occasional humor so that it's not just
all these issues punching you in the
face there's humor injected into it and
I also find his characters relatable
when they're you know he creates a
humanity the ability for the character
to resonate with the reader and he's
done that in all the projects that he's
worked on right I always feel connected
to whoever the characters are which is
always something that I value I want to
be able to connect to the characters and
really engage in their story because
that's what keeps me engaged so some of
the examples that I brought I meant to
bring why the last man but when I write
when I moved to Japan I donated like 70
percent of my comic collection to the
school I used to work at so um it's at
that school right now if you haven't
checked out why the last man it's a
great one to just toss people into too
if they're a first-time comic reader
a lot of people will read that very
graciously I guess conversation you and
I were having before the show that was
the first comic book series I ever
introduced my wife - mm-hmm she knew who
Superman was she didn't want to pick up
an issue and have to have had 30 years
worth of history in order to read
today's issue but so I gave her by the
last man and again the exact same
reasons right she loved it resonated
with her like it was a fantastic story
mm-hmm yeah yeah and I also have a set
of Runaways but my kids are super into
it right now
so they're all checked out of my library
so there's that there's also saga which
honestly if you have not checked out
saga yet you really should it's probably
one of the most talked about comic books
recently just because of the controversy
of the cover but it's also just a
fantastic story um the same thing with
pride of Baghdad came out oh my gosh
that's I can't even think what 2003
maybe something around there it has been
a while but it is just a great story
that touches on some of the issues
happening in Baghdad with the bombings
that we do in Iraq the u.s. does but
it's again told in a great way where you
don't feel like I said punched in the
face would be issues it's a great way to
tackle it while still having humanity
despite the fact that it's told from
Lions from the perspective of the Lions
right right yeah so Bryan cave on check
out his stuff - I know who's your
favorite writer that's uh Bryan Lee
O'Malley if you can't tell um he's great
this is one of those comics that made me
feel like it was cool to like comics
because it was sort of in when I was
coming out so I didn't have to like
suppress that as much I remember going
to the sixth book release dressed as
Ramona Flowers actually my blue hair
days when I used to die at a crazy color
every week so obviously when I read it I
was like what this is an amazing
character um he won like the 2015 Joe
Shuster Award for outstanding Canadian
comic book cartoonist as a writer and
one of the good ones to read for his is
lost at sea this is one of his beginning
ones at Oni Press and it's sort of like
this existential like aimlessness - it
talks about like depression and breakups
and goes through like her divorce her
parents divorce not hers
and she has to take this road trip home
with these acquaintances she knew from
like high school and dealing with
possibly not having a soul but feeling
like she's just like walking around
without a soul this emptiness there's
just a really great relatability of
having to be around people that you
don't necessarily want to be around
during like a really like big moment of
vulnerability that I really like about
this and there's some other smaller lost
at sea like continuation comics out
there online you can look them up I'm
sure there's also seconds which is
Katie's like a restaurant owner that one
I don't own apparently but it's a little
more fast-paced and has more expositions
than I'm used to in his stuff he sort of
like throws you and usually that one
kind of gives you an introduction to her
life but I would say he's best known for
Scott Pilgrim obviously which won the
2010 Harvey and Eisner Award for Best
humor publication um I mean it's a video
game ish type of world there's
superpowers there's music I like there's
one of the beginning a commerce a might
be issued one actually when they're like
making a recipe and it's like cook along
with how to make a vegan shepherd's pie
because if you're vegan your superpowers
in this world it's amazing and it's very
reminiscent of like failed high school
romances and bad breakups not that I can
but I just yeah I just remember going
nuts for Ramona as a character and all
the other characters are just so unique
and quirky and just just
unapologetically quirky and their own
cells but still grounded and like a
reality even if they're dealing with
things like magic mushrooms or like
having to defeat evil exes or like your
soul being stuck in a cat
stuff like that uh you know just like
normal stuff for people go through so
even if they're in like a world with
eccentricities to it they're still like
cool characters but they're still
grounded in reality and he has new is a
new graphic novel coming out he
announced it at SDCC
worst world true to the source material
which does not usually happen and it
completely took its own spin like the
ending is completely different and
there's a lot of difference right yeah
so it's very like it's it's different
but it really really gave that true
essence of what it was to like read it
Scott the casting was amazing reverence
Porter right we all know like you saw in
the Facebook video I love Jeff Jones
everybody knows I love Scott Schneider
but one of my favorite writers that I
only got to read a very small portion
was Joss Whedon he did the astonishing
x-men run like 24 issues and then like a
giant-sized it is amazing Joss Whedon is
one of my favorite directors of all time
and he's he can he's such a good writer
he you know from you know Buffy Angel
dollhouse he he can do he can write all
of these characters serenity fires like
write all these characters with like big
teams and everybody has a very specific
personality and he doesn't skimp on
anybody everybody is fully fleshed out
and they've completely related but for
the most part relatable personality and
you can you can find yourself in
something of every one of these
characters and him the tackling the
x-men is perfect because of how
different these characters are but
they're all you know together because
they're mutants and his his level of
snark and humor is awesome with a lot of
these characters but he can write like
big somatic events and like the main
thing here especially the first trade
they're talking about a potential mutant
cure and how all the mutants deal with
that and that's a big thing you know
be human and how they deal with it and
it they he captured the character so
well and they could have these big
moments and then he'll just throw in a
joss whedon line that you just you if
you weren't if you didn't know like how
much of this is like we didn't read or a
road or whatever you hear this line it's
like that's a joss whedon liar but it
doesn't take away from the story it adds
a bit of brevity but it just enhances
the story even more it makes it more
relatable the characters and it's just
so good one of my favorite characters in
astonishing x-men it's actually Kitty
Pryde which almost completely like she's
like pretty much the center of the story
overall and she's such a good character
and it's it's amazing and he captures
everybody a lot and but I think you
really captured Kitty Pryde especially
in what I have all four trades like I
got a friend of mine who's borrowing but
whenever I read the trades I read them
all all four of them in one go just I
just sit down and read them all the last
the last few pages of the last trade man
it gives me goosebumps the first time I
read it I cried the second time I read
it I cried like it was it's just if
there's so much weight to it to these
characters and you love them so much in
just twenty four issues and I wish that
he wrote more comic books I I would I
would read anything that he wrote
regardless of the art style regardless
of what it was about it was a kids not
like a kid's comic book I'd be at that
every Wednesday you know I loved
everything that we does and he I've
never been disappointed ever a world
with more but I loved Whedon he's so
good
so we're gonna go to favorite artists
now Trevor who is your favorite artist
yes so a little different for me because
my favorite artists are the ones that I
work with but I don't want to be
self-aggrandizing by any measure so
instead I kind of twisted your question
a little bit to be like an artist that
I'm very intrigued by and I'm kind of
watching their career and so for me
that's an artist named treadmore who
fans will probably know more famously
from the run that he did on Marvel's
Ghost Rider but I know him from the
Luthor's strode books that my buddy
Justin Jordan writes and yes this is a
very hyper violent book as you can
probably tell from the cover you know
but it's it's essentially the thing that
I love about him the most is the way
that he kind of flows from panel to
panel page to page action to action and
again narrative flow is very visual
within comics so it's very important to
be able to capture that it was a very
action heavy series and he has actions
that he'll put in there that'll just
flow your eye very organically through
the rest of the page through the actions
that are happening it's almost like
watching a kung-fu fight scene in many
ways so I absolutely love what trad has
been doing with with this series which
has now ended and the third trade as
well as some of the stuff that he's been
doing for Marvel so I'm keeping a very
close eye on what he's gonna be working
on next yeah um so one of my favorite
comic book artists is Adam Hughes that's
why I've got the Satana DC women of DC
Universe a--
bust over here i just really love the
way that he treats women in his art in
general
I love his like compositions even like I
feel like it's very realistic which I
like in value and I also just really
appreciate that a lot of his stuff even
though it's kind of pinup II still has
that old feel of their personalities
shine through it's not just about the
like sexy cute pose that Catwoman is
doing it's about there's a story in
there like you can look at something
even like this bust and see that there's
a story here you know she's reaching
can't find the rabbit or whatever she's
looking for
all of the personality that he puts in
every picture I guess that he
illustrates here one of the things that
made me fall in love with him one of the
first illustrations that I saw was like
oh my gosh I love this guy is this one
where it's the women of the DC Universe
all together so it makes the point where
like they're not even in their costumes
but you can tell exactly who is who not
because of any facial features cuz even
some of their hair is different than it
usually is but just the way that they're
posed you can tell oh that's totally
Wonder Woman or Catwoman or whatever so
I love the personality that he puts in
all the woman in the DC Universe there
and he's currently doing some of the
covers for Betty and Veronica and
they're adorable adorable Ayanna who's
your favorite artist David Mac um some
of you might know him from the Winter
Soldier credit sequence that was bomb he
did that or if or Fight Club - I know
people have been talking about a lot he
does the cover art for that but he does
more than just watercolor watercolor is
what I love him for because there's some
breathtaking ones an alias specifically
or daredevil - but he does more than
just watercolor and pen and ink he does
magazine clippings and color scans and
crayons and thread and lace and he sees
a collage and it's an amazing amazing
work um he has his own series that he
wrote kabuki which is actually if you
have the comiXology app I believe volume
one is free on unlimited right now um so
go check that out um and it was his
senior thesis in college was Volume one
that's what he turned in first thesis so
um it's black and white and it's set in
Japan in the future and it's like an
assassin named kabuki and it's awesome
it's a bunch of like assassins in the
future it's it's very violent warning
but it didn't like and why it's so like
the blood is like artistically needs are
there is
one of the later volumes is in in full
color though so but he'll use like
sandalwood sans is like panel borders or
bar I'd like turn like the barbed wire
like into burbs like MC Escher style and
then or like someone will raise a sickle
and then it'll turn into like the
crescent moon just some of the the
images that he evokes in that series is
really really really cool and it aleena
specifically is what I love him for is
his cover work for that and it's very
like feminine Juarez what Ben just calls
it and he'll use he'll he made like a
whole journal for this character in it
that this girl gets lost and runs away
or something we don't know what happens
to her and he makes an entire like dream
journal for her this entire thing he
just makes up for her and it's amazing
um and it's based off of one of his like
ex girlfriends from college and stuff he
co-created EKKO I cheated I chose like
two writer and artists for mine so I got
like double out of it yeah with each
other and stuff he's also one of the
nicest guys you'll ever meet in the
comics mine is a little bit more
well-known it's Jim Lee and I love Jim
Lee's art so much I think he captures
you see him a lot in DC now and he does
a lot of Batman it'll do you know he did
Superman unchained which was phenomenal
it was written by Scott Snyder and it
was such a good run but he captured
Superman and he gets the he gets the
feel of Superman with the way he draws
this costume I think I really liked him
leave Superman costume it's it's crisp
it's clean but it feels a very Superman
and I love the way he draws Batman
specifically I think the way he uses his
shadows with Batman fits like you know
the whole Batman persona of the life in
the shadows Dark Knight but I think he
shadows him well and it just really
draws out that character and he pops on
on every page even if he's in the dark
and I just love the way it looks his
lines are so like good and clean it just
it looks great but then he busts out
like this crazy
Joker here that it's insane it's not
your normal style Joker but it still
looks awesome and he just he ditched
these characters really well and but he
brings something fresh to them and I
love their realistic but they're also
their own that it's their own style like
I don't I don't see anybody that draws
Batman and Superman together like this
that just flows like like it does in
these pages and that ain't hush is one
of my favorite books of all time and his
entire run on this story
it's just beautiful he does beautiful
artwork and I love it I just love it so
much all right well I hope you guys
enjoyed talking about our fair writer
and artist we're gonna do pic of the
week I was gonna say is all of this
stuff yeah all this stuff that we've
mentioned go and check it out because
it's a great work you have a lot of
homework to do social media for everyone
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse or Instagram at a truce and Porter
how about you facebook.com slash awesome
border okay I on Twitter Facebook
snapchat now good here fighting crime
there yeah what do you got going on here
anything coming out recently what's up
yeah so we continue to work on my Albert
the alien series which is a webcomic
that updates for free every Wednesday
and Friday at Albert the alien calm it's
a young reader sci-fi series about the
first foreign exchange student from
outer space I love my artists so check
that out it's totally free and then
we'll be kickstart funding the third
graphic novel in that series probably
early next year great and then you can
find me online as well at Facebook
Twitter Instagram Trevor a Muller is all
of those things so find me follow me
friend me and let's let's talk comics
great I hope you've enjoyed watching us
talk comics next week and preparation
for the season 3 premiere of the flash
we will be reviewing Justice League the
flashpoint paradox animated movie so
come back for that you can also follow
me on twitter at awesome underscore
Walter talk to me about top 5 so I do
this year whatever
okay so until next week for these guys
the fantastic people I'm Walter burn AZ
egg and we will see you on the next page
you